on this thursday night a significant
moment at the vatican it gave me a real
sense of optimism after a two-hour
meeting with the pope indigenous leaders
emerged with expectations from the
catholic church pleading not to be
forgotten you're not paying attention to
us former afghan interpreters who work
side by side with canada's military go
on a hunger strike i cannot see my
children i cannot see my wife the new
mission to evacuate mariupol as russian
forces appear to stall what is vladimir
putin's plan
and russia's invasion rocks the boat
they spend
hundreds of millions of dollars on them
tracking the super yachts of russia's
super rich
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
in vatican city today this was their
moment songs of support and strength
from a delegation led by the assembly of
first nations after a long-awaited
meeting with the head of the catholic
church pope francis met them in private
for two hours a milestone they said in
the journey of reconciliation over the
church's role in residential schools
wilton little child is a survivor and a
former commissioner of canada's truth
and reconciliation commission he spent
14 years in three different residential
schools
tomorrow
is my birthday
and
the gift
we receive today or i receive today
it's a good day
that tomorrow
will be the first day
of reconciliation
good evening and thanks for joining us
residential schools are closed now but
there is much the catholic church still
needs to answer for about the terrible
legacy they've left crystal gomencing is
in rome crystal what was the tone of
this meeting what are delegates saying
about it
donna there's been a lot of hope
expressed here there's a sense that
after hearing from three groups of
delegates
explaining what they endured as children
in residential schools the pope must
have a deeper appreciation and it's
hoped that that will lead to the
long-awaited apology
echoing through the ancient corridors of
saint peter's square a traditional first
nation song calling to spirit a calling
to stand and be strong that is exactly
what three groups of metis inuit and
first nations residential school
survivors have done as they've met with
pope francis while forgiveness is a
personal choice we cannot ignore the
power of an apology
and the act of forgiveness
that demonstrates compassion
in which we are able
to show that we are transforming anger
and hurt into a healing process of peace
love and freedom
in an effort to show mutual respect and
understanding as a part of a journey of
healing elder fred kelly bestowed an
indigenous name on the pontiff white
feather delegates also presented a
number of gifts including a beaded
brooch and an eagle feather a
cradleboard something to hold and look
at until the delegates meet his holiness
together on friday was also presented
it's meant to have him think about the
thousands of children who did not come
home from residential schools
i come from the peace and friendship
treaty area
and my dad would always say
you know there's no peace and we have
yet to find our friends
and i think right now the work that
we've done and the work of
all those who have come before us you
know we're really set setting that path
forward the two-hour meeting with the
first nations delegates was the final
effort to instill on the pope the deep
and long-lasting wounds inflicted by the
residential school system
largely run by the catholic church
and the calls for an official apology
have been as long and as passionate as
the march led through saint peter's
square
our preference is for the
it's for the holy father to come to
canada apologize on canadian soil
and do it on one of our territories that
is our hope and wish and we made that
very clear to
the holy father
phil fontaine says it is looking
promising for a papal visit to canada
and he used his meeting with the pope to
suggest winnipeg as the first location
of that visit of course the city was
also the first sharing session by the
truth and reconciliation commission in
2010. donna crystal commencing in rome
tonight thanks a 24-hour crisis line is
available to support residential school
survivors it's toll free you can speak
in confidence the number is
1-800-721-0066
now to ukraine heavy fighting and
shelling is still going on near kiev and
it's still difficult getting people out
of the worst-hit cities ukrainian
officials say at least one person was
killed when a humanitarian convoy was
hit near the northern city of cherniav
and in the south the international red
cross now says a planned evacuation from
the besieged city of mary opal won't
happen until tomorrow for security and
logistical reasons redmond shannon
reports
life in mariupol is simply about
survival
pavel has survived but his friend was
not so lucky buried here by a roadside
one of 5 000 deaths in the city
according to the mayor's office
with no power or water those still here
improvise
we cook what we can find says victor
some help is now on its way though 45
buses headed towards mariupol on
thursday behind me there's medicine
there's food there's hygiene items the
red cross says it has agreements with
moscow to get some people out under a
ceasefire on friday but some previous
evacuation efforts have fallen apart
russian leader vladimir putin issued a
decree thursday it says that as of
friday so-called unfriendly nations must
buy russian natural gas in rubles not
euros or else he will turn off the tap
and what is their quotes german
chancellor olaf schultz said gas
contracts clearly state customers can
pay in euros or dollars euro pays around
400 million us dollars per day
for the gas it gets from russia
and given the current sanctions russia
cannot stay without these revenues this
energy expert says putin's decree allows
payments in euros with russian banks
simply exchanging them for rubles i
think
this is really a face saving move by the
kremlin in other words putin can spin
this to russians as a victory
in washington another energy move
president joe biden looking to reduce
war inflated prices at the pumps by
releasing 1 million barrels of u.s oil
reserves a day
this is a wartime bridge to increase oil
supply until production ramps up later
this year but just how long will the war
last
night ukrainian president vladimir
zelinski warns that russian troops are
repositioning in the east near the
disputed donbass region just as his
troops make gains in the north ukraine
says peace talks will resume online on
friday redmond shannon global news
london president biden was asked today
whether he thinks vladimir putin has
been misinformed by his inner circle
about russia's military performance
here's what he said
he seems to be self-isolated
and there's some indication that he has
um
fired or put under house arrest some of
his advisors
um but i i don't want to put too much
stock in that at this time because we
don't have that much hard evidence the
head of the uk's intelligence service
suspects putin's advisers are afraid to
tell him the truth and claim russian
soldiers have refused to carry out
orders it's impossible to know exactly
what is going on inside the kremlin
though as eric sorenson reports history
can offer some lessons
russian military advances have stalled
but what comes next
western intelligence says vladimir putin
may not be fully informed by his own
intimidated military having misjudged
the resistance and resolve of the
ukrainians it all adds up to the
strategic miscalculation
that our leaders warned putin it would
be but history also suggests putin may
well carry on
years ago in chechnya russian troops
also suffered major setbacks this global
news report summed up western thinking
in 1999. the kremlin's initial boast
that victory in cheshnia would be swift
and decisive is proving to be a costly
miscalculation it sounds familiar but
even then a young vladimir putin
dismissed international condemnation
the war in chechnya did not end for
another 10 years certainly when you look
at putin's uh invasions you see this
reckless disregard for for human life
for civilian life the russians bombed
chechnya into submission the devastation
in the capital grozny the shell-shocked
civilians all acceptable to putin in
2016 russia's bombing campaign in aleppo
syria left utter destruction and
refugees defend for themselves what's
happening now in mariupol and other
ukrainian cities is not new it is
brutality we've seen before these are
the kinds of things that you learn that
you can bomb and use armor but it's not
as effective in ukraine when you're
dealing with a much larger country a
much more determined opposition with
much better weaponry when russia began
its invasion five weeks ago it already
controlled crimea and much of the
donbass region of ukraine since then the
russian military has gained control of
areas in the north close to kiev and
kharkiv and in the south creating a link
between the donbass and crimea that has
destroyed mariupol but ukrainian forces
are contesting many areas and while
russia has launched attacks all over the
country it is concentrated in the
eastern part of ukraine is that putin's
new plan whether he's actually pulling
back
and going to say i'm just going to focus
on the dom boss and i'm not worried
about the rest of the country
i'm a skeptic mistrust for a leader who
in the past has met resistance with
deception and more firepower eric
sorensen global news toronto
a delegation from ukraine's parliament
attended question period in ottawa today
and received a warm welcome
five mps were given a lengthy standing
ovation they're in ottawa for high-level
talks that include the prime minister
[Applause]
i know
this can't be an easy trip for you i
know you want to be
back there but what you're doing what
you did in washington what you're doing
here today
really really matters
the mps also met privately with the
deputy prime minister well the federal
government is committing an additional
50 million dollars in support for
afghanistan to avert what it calls an
unprecedented disaster there but more
than 100 afghan interpreters who worked
with the canadian military are feeling
forgotten and as abigail beeman reports
they showed up on parliament hill today
mr trudeau should imagine if he's here
and
if his wife is in afghanistan what will
he do
you know what will he do for his
children please do that with
for our children
about a hundred former afghanistan
interpreters in the cold and rain on a
three-day hunger strike to raise
awareness separated from their families
overseas with heartbreaking story after
heartbreaking story he's in turkey right
now hiding there
and the other one is still missing i'm
super depressed
you're not paying attention to us
we accomplished the mission with you in
afghanistan some have families still in
afghanistan others fled to a neighboring
country some say because canada told
them to they told me to move your family
to a third country my family is stuck in
pakistan for months
and your visa is about to getting
expired i understand how heartbreaking
it is to be separated from from family
members the immigration minister points
to some of the complications pakistan's
exit requirement of an afghan passport
which could only be issued by the
taliban despite the extraordinary nature
of these logistical challenges we're not
wavering in our commitment to do what we
can to make good on the promise to bring
people here under this special stream
that we've created to this group the
stream he references is already a broken
promise launched to make it easier for
extended families of previously
resettled interpreters to come to canada
those protesting say of about 300
families who qualify zero have arrived
here the department did not confirm
numbers by deadline that was a horrible
job we work with the front line we work
with the canadian soldiers side by side
we have been along the missions it means
like we are in a really beautiful prison
i cannot see my family i cannot see my
children i cannot see my wife abigail
beeman global news ottawa
money on the mind coming up the
priorities for canadians ahead of next
week's federal budget
[Music]
the transportation safety board says
aging breaks extreme cold and an
inexperienced train master led to a
deadly train derailment near the alberta
bc border three years ago three cp rail
workers died when the locomotive
plummeted off a bridge in february 2019
investigators found old brake cylinders
exposed to temperatures near minus 30
failed while parked on a steep grade
canadians will be watching next week's
federal budget closely to see how the
government plans to ease the cost of
living a new ipsos poll done for global
news shows the majority of canadians
want help with soaring prices our chief
political correspondent david aiken is
digging through the details for us
well donna previous trudeau government
budgets have really focused on a build
back better theme money to transform
society and the world but the mood has
now shifted canadians are looking for a
budget that eases the strain on their
household finances what we're seeing is
that people have a very clear priority
and that is dealing with the cost of
living ipsos asked 1500 canadians to
pick three top priorities for next
week's budget measures to help with the
high cost of living topped the list with
53 naming that as a top three priority
45 percent said lowering taxes is a top
priority and 40 percent wanted greater
investments in health care and while the
war in ukraine has exposed shortcomings
in canada's military readiness just 11
said ottawa should spend more on defense
i think canadians are not saying that
they don't want the government to spend
money on defense but in terms of the
priorities that they have in terms of
their relative
situation their personal situation their
day-to-day lives what's happening to you
today matters more than anything else
this is the first budget since the ndp
liberal confidence and supply agreement
and for that reason the trudeau
government may be less interested in the
budget priorities identified in this
ipsos poll
and more interested in the budget
priorities of judgment singh donna all
right david aiken thanks canada's carbon
tax is going up next what it could mean
for you
[Music]
the federal carbon tax goes up tomorrow
it was brought in to induce changes in
behavior of consumers and companies to
steer them away from fossil fuels it's
going up 25 to 50 dollars per ton of
emissions and gaviola breaks down what
that could mean for you and for the
environment
even though prices at the pumps have
taken a breather this week there's more
sticker shock in store the timing
couldn't be worse with
the massive increase in energy prices
ottawa figures the federal carbon tax
hike works out to an extra 2.2 cents per
liter of gas bringing the total carbon
tax cost to 11 cents per liter for
consumers this will hit the wallets of
motorists in alberta saskatchewan
manitoba and ontario provinces that
don't have their own carbon pricing
schemes in place if they do notice it
they won't know for sure whether it's
caused by the federal carbon tax or
whether it's caused by changes in crude
oil prices or wholesale prices or just
retail margins but these types of
increases push up the price of other
everyday things from food to household
items the bank of canada estimates the
carbon tax as it is now pushes inflation
up by just under half a percent
ottawa says four out of five canadians
will end up ahead financially because of
rebates claimed through federal taxes
but the parliamentary budget watchdog
disagrees saying most people affected by
the carbon tax will see an overall
negative economic impact what it means
for you depends on how much money you
make and where you live the lowest
income households in ontario will see a
150 carbon tax benefit this year while
the highest earners will be out more
than eleven hundred dollars in alberta
that's 246 dollars back for the lowest
income families while the top earners
will be out of pocket nearly two
thousand dollars the carbon tax puts a
price on pollution and is designed to
incentivize greener choices that means
choosing transit carpooling or less
commuting can mitigate some of the
impact ann gaviola global news toronto
nowhere to sail nowhere to hide next
searching for the super yachts of
russia's elite
yacht spotting is a thing these days and
it's become even more popular now that
so many russian oligarchs have been
sanctioned freezing their assets
including their multi-million dollar
super yachts they might prefer to sail
under the radar but as mike relay
reports yacht spotters are on the case
they say russian oligarchs are masters
in the dark arts of finance but they're
not magicians and super yachts are just
too big and opulent to hide so there
they are the largest vessels on earth
frozen in place thanks to russian
sanctions
even in so-called friendly ports they
haven't exactly been welcomed in norway
the ragnar was stuck for a month and a
half because no one would sell them fuel
no wonder they're turning off their
transponders well
what's happening now is a few of them
appear to be
turning them off because they don't want
to be tracked and technically this is
illegal but it's very hard to enforce
but a lot of a lot of yachts that are
associated with
naughty people
we haven't had a signal for days weeks
finding the yachts is one thing
determining who owns them is another
since oligarchs use shell companies to
hide their assets that's where xcia
officer alex finley says virtual sleuths
have stepped in in the most millennial
of ways through instagram we've seen
that
the younger generation doesn't have the
same sense of security or they didn't
get the same security briefing i think
as the oligarchs did
so we have seen a number of cases where
the children or step children or
ex-wives of some of these people um have
taken
like you said they take photos here i am
on a yacht here i am next to a pool here
i am doing all these really cool things
even so the vanity of 20 year olds is
likely not enough for a court to
determine ownership and even if that can
be proven seizing property without proof
is theft if you're going to expropriate
people yeah you have to prove their
linkage to criminal or unlawful conduct
and that is something the law will
require
this 850 million ship moored in italy is
believed to be owned by vladimir putin
himself
if so and he wants it back he's looking
at a legal battle that could last years
i'm not sure if you've been in legal
proceedings before but being in a
wishy-washy position with no
kind of end date no court date is
actually a good position to be in and so
why not take advantage of that most if
not all of the oligarchs will likely get
their yachts back until then summer on
the med is off
mike relay global news toronto
that's global national for this thursday
i'm donna friesen on this day when
indigenous leaders met the pope at the
vatican we also want to point out its
national indigenous languages day more
than 70 indigenous languages are spoken
across this country sol mamacwa a member
of the kingfisher lake first nation and
an ontario mpp released a message today
about why that matters we leave you with
part of it thanks for watching
our languages allow us to share our
stories
about
who we are
and where we come from
this is where i learned my language this
is where i learned the history of my
grandparents the people
the bays
the islands the real names of the places
around me
be glad to everyone working to keep this
resource this way of life safe and
living
for future generations
[Music]
oh